Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
For joining us for our 58th episode!
BAU BAU!
It's a new week, and a new FUWAMOCO Morning!
And maybe if there's some new Ruffians joining us for the first time, we should explain what FUWAMOCO Morning is.
We should.
It would be wrong of us to continue without it.
While FUWAMOCO Morning is short for that morning show,
Every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Yeah!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Well, to start off this morning, there was yet another peron sighting!
We have from a certain Ruffian, this!
Oh!
Pero's become a digital desktop buddy!
That's cute!
Yeah, it's kind of oddly fitting for him, no?
Right?
Yeah.
He looks good on digital.
I like it.
Very cute.
Sometimes, you know, Ruffians, we have questions when it comes to things on the computer, so it'd be great to get some advice from someone.
Someone!
Anyone!
I guess someone maybe we're a bit familiar with.
You know, when we're unsure, right?
Yeah.
It seems like Pero is suggesting to this Ruffian that they do some updates.
Formatting their hard drives.
Yeah.
Sometimes my cu-cu-cu-cu-computer.
Computer.
It asks for updates too.
Right.
You know, I'm pretty kind.
I do the updates regularly.
Formatting the hard drive too.
We've actually never done that before.
It never asked me to do that.
Are we behind?
Should we do that sometime, Ruffians?
Actually, you know, we really need to organize all our files.
I think we talked about it before, but maybe we'll do that sometime together with you Ruffians and then we can format our hard drive after.
Right!
Does that sound like a good plan?
Yeah!
And then, you know, everything can be fresh and ready for us to go afterwards for the new year.
But that's really kind of Pero to help you out with that.
Nice advice.
Right, but she's usually so nasty, but... BAU BAU!
That's a nice Pero sign.
It's been a while, huh?
Yeah, a little while, right?
But... Ruffians.
RuffianS!
We have some really, really happy, happy news!
Wow, Ruffians, it's serious.
You might know.
You might know already, but... We still really can't believe it.
But thanks to all your support, it seems like we won the League of their Own category at the VTuber Awards!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
We're so honored and amazed.
There are some really amazing VTubers that we are competing with.
And you know, we're just newbies.
We're really happy to just be nominated, you know?
But we somehow won thanks to all your support and votes.
Thank you!
We're not the super competitive type, but we hope that this award will maybe put some more eyes on us and to what we've been doing and, you know, maybe some big ones too.
Hopefully!
You know, because there are a lot of very talented and amazing members and senpai within hololive, you know?
So, we want to make sure that we can stand out and stand on our own two!
We're going to work really hard, continue to work really hard, and hopefully we can stand out a bit.
Maybe it's silly, you know, because we're twins and maybe you think that we stand out already, but...
We're gonna do our best, okay?
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And other happy advent news!
Nerissa!
Nerissa's new song cover of Idolmaster's Shiny Colors S.O.S is now on!
Ruffians!
Have you listened?
Go listen, Ruffians!
No, it's Nerissa's cutest cover yet!
It's so good, right?
It's so good!
I love it when she gets all pouty, too.
Yeah.
So cute!
But yeah, it's Nerissa's most idly sounding cover yet, so it's really cute to get to hear a different side of her and her voice.
Yeah.
And you know, previously she just released a more operatic song, like Lilium, and now it's such a cute idol pop song, like S.O.S.
Going from those two, it's really definitely something else.
Wow.
Has to be Nerissa.
She's so amazing.
Such a versatile voice.
Please go check it out on GamerFu.
It's so good.
BAU BAU!
Lots of amazing things have been happening to you, but not just within Advent, though.
Kiara-senpai!
Ruffians, did you check out Kiara-senpai's 3D Birthday at the end of year live?
Did you?
It happened over the weekend!
In full 3D with lots of guests, too.
You know, we really wanted to stay up to watch it live, but...
BAU BAU!
I sometimes sing it at karaoke too.
So it was really cool to see it performed with the original choreography too.
I really like Noble Kiss too, but I think my favorite was probably Kiara-senpai and Calli-senpai's performance of their new original song together, Fire and Ice.
You know, I just felt like there's a very special bond that I could see that they shared as they sang and danced it together.
So that was my favorite part.
But you know, the choreography was also very cool and very cute.
I thought it was appropriate for, you know, fire and ice.
Me too!
BAU BAU!
Wow.
Ruffians.
I think this is maybe the third time we've talked about this on FUWAMOCO Morning.
What does that mean?
Is that a bad thing or a good thing?
No, it's a good thing.
But Ruffians, you might know that recently hololive has opened up a pop-up shop in Tokyo Station's very famous Character Street.
We talked about it before.
You should maybe know.
Yeah!
And I'm enjoying it this summer!
Ruffians, you know, you know that
You really wanted to get your paws on them, but it's kind of tricky.
It's tricky, huh?
Yeah, you need to kind of be in Japan, and then you need to be really lucky too.
But you know it.
It seems, just seems, just seems, that there have been some Ruffians taking matters into their own paws.
And have been picking them up on second-hand resale sites.
Ruffians.
What are you doing?
It says, no resale!
There's supposed to be special treasures to say thank you for your purchase!
You know, at the very least, you should trade with others to get your ornament, and not buying it from places like that, right?
Right?
But you know, I get it.
When you're overseas and can't actually go there in person, but you really really want it, but...
I get it, but... But still... Actually, Moco-chan.
It seems that Advent has been putting a high price together, like, as a set.
Yeah.
Oh, Moco-chan, can you tell me?
Can you BAU me?
Yup, I'll just... Oh.
Oh!
This much.
Hoi!
What the heck?
And, uh, us, like, FUWAMOCO, as it's said together, was... Hoi!
Ruffians!
Hi!
Please, please.
Just take it easy until you can get proper merchandise, okay?
Okay.
Got it.
You know it.
Something might be just around the corner.
Something.
Okay, no Ruffians.
Can you guess?
Christmas.
Birthday!
Just remember these cards are supposed to be presents, okay?
Not reselling, okay?
Got it?
Got it.
BAU BAU!
But you know, I'm happy that the Ruffians are so excited and passionate too.
I get it.
Well, Moco-chan, actually we got a very important scoop from a FUWAMOCO fan!
A FUWAMOCO scoop?
Yeah!
Thank you FUWAMOCO fan for the very good journalism.
A++++.
Well, let's take a look at our scoop here.
Let's see, we have...
Oh!
Oh no.
It looks like Matsuri-senpai... Matsuri-senpai has come down with a bad case of BAU BAU BYOU.
Oh no, Ruffians!
What are we gonna do, huh?
We still don't have a cure for BAU BAU BYOU, huh?
It's been how many months now?
Five months?
Well, not only has she been making a number of questionable tweets.
Yeah, like, uh, saying she wants to give birth to FUWAMOCO.
Yeah, but- Whatever that means!
She's also been caught popping into our super chat reading just the other day, too, and, uh, she also said on a stream, Ruffians, uh, Ko-chan, you read it.
Oh, why do I have to read it?
I don't want to read it, it's embarrassing.
Moco-chan, what did Matsuri-senpai say?
She said... Do I have to say it in her words?
I have to say it in her words?
I really wanna kiss them.
Kiss me, FUWAMOCO.
Oh my gosh, Ruffians!
Ruffians!
What should we do to help Matsuri-senpai's BAU BAU feel?
I don't know!
What should we do, huh?
Do you know?
Avoid at all costs.
It's not gonna make the problem better.
It's incurable.
I see some very bad advice.
Very bad advice.
I see some bad advice too.
Ask Bae-senpai for advice.
That might be a good idea.
Bae-senpai has very good advice.
Based on the Ruffians.
But the Ruffians gave us that advice.
I don't know.
I don't know, yeah.
She needs help.
Maybe we'll ask Bae-senpai.
BAU BAU!
Hopefully she's okay.
Hopefully.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians.
I just kinda asked the Ruffians for help, but... We need your help again!
We need it again!
I know.
Sooner than our birthday.
Sooner than our birthday?
Christmas is coming up really soon, right?
Really soon!
Yeah.
Well, we wanted to share something really... Oh.
No.
We don't want to share something with you.
We need you to share something really important with us!
Moco-chan, please make sure you don't get your words all mixed up, okay?
Coming from you!
We need you to share something with us!
Yes!
Something very personal, okay?
Important!
You have to reminisce a bit, okay?
Is that okay?
Are you good with that?
Well... What?
Personal, but... No.
No.
Reminisce, okay?
Yeah.
Yeah, well, Ruffians!
We wanted to... to hear...
We wanted to hear some of your favorite holiday Christmas memories.
Yeah!
Please share them with us.
Well, we opened up a Google Form.
And that way, you can share them with us there!
We only have a few simple rules though.
We'd like to ask that your memory... I know it's hard sometimes to have good memories that are very robust.
But we'd like to ask that your memory be around 150 to 500 words.
So it's not too long.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Not so much violence.
A little violence.
And try to avoid any third-party IPs and alarms.
So if maybe there's a whole live member that's a good part of your Christmas memories, then that's okay.
Hopefully we can be that one tonight, Moco-chan.
Yeah!
We'll do our best to read as many of your memories as possible, but
But you have until Saturday, December 23rd at 6pm PT to submit yours, okay?
You have a bit of time.
A bit of time.
We'll share the link in the description and on Twitter as well, so please get writing, okay, Ruffians?
You know, it could be anything.
Yeah, you know, a good memory helping out.
Dinner!
Sounds good!
Guess what?
We have some more good news.
It looks like there's been
No misunderstandings!
Except for the, you know, fact that we kind of forgot that there was no misunderstandings last time.
So, uh, two days without misunderstandings.
Yeah!
New record, right?
New high score!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Why?
But you know, even we, we went through lethal company with no misunderstandings.
Even a very silly rock n' roll party, no misunderstandings!
It's that time of the week.
That time of the week where Moco-chan challenges herself.
To some delicious NANTA!
Moco-chan, you know, she's been doing very, uh...
I'm doing my best to eat natto.
Natto!
For Ruffians who aren't quite familiar, natto is a very popular breakfast food in Japan.
It's really good for you.
Very healthy.
Lots of vitamins, but it's also a little sticky and slimy and a bit strong smelling.
Last week I did very well.
Well, we used the new secret technique.
Sesame oil.
Yeah.
So... And last time I ate three.
Three beans.
Yeah.
So this time, Ruffians, I have prepared the sesame oil.
Do you have confidence in me, Ruffians?
Hai.
Moco-chan, today I would like you to eat, like, a lot of beans.
BAU BAU!
Okay, well, last time I felt like I put a bit too much sesame oil in it.
But I think I'll put a bit too much.
I am treating, okay?
Okay, that's... Okay.
It's kind of swimming.
Not dory swimming, okay?
It's swimming in the oil now.
This should be good.
Yeah.
Oh, it's dripping.
How?
There's a hole in it.
There's a hole in it!
That's a first.
I'm getting oily.
Oh gosh, it's dripping all over me!
It's getting on my skirt.
Oh no.
There's natto and sesame oil everywhere.
Moco-chan.
How did this happen?
What did you do?
What the heck?
Did you hurt the packaging?
I didn't hurt it.
Maybe the natto, they wanted to escape.
That's it.
Well, Moco-chan.
What is this?
I think this is really nice and fluffy now.
But Moco-chan.
For some reason, it looks worse than last week.
What are we gonna do this time?
What do you mean?
Before you challenge yourself- I don't eat the open package food, that's what I feel.
Ha!
If the package was injured then we shouldn't eat it.
Oh no.
It's fine.
Don't say the Ruffians, it's fine!
Okay, Moco-chan!
Last time it was very rude and you didn't say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi.
So this time you need to say an extra, extra big thank you to the farmers in Tochigi for all your hard work.
Thank you.
That's pretty small, Moco-chan.
That's still pretty small.
Tochigi Farmers and Sesame Oil Farmers.
Sesame Oil Farmers too, yeah?
Thank you.
Oh, this looks pretty delicious, Moco-chan.
I'm excited for you.
Yeah.
Wow, that's a big oily puddle!
I don't want... I don't want oil all over me.
You're good, Moco-chan.
I don't want oil all over me.
Where's the hole on it?
Where is the hole on it?
It's here.
Oh, okay.
Why is it like that?
I'm just covered in it.
I think that's suspicious.
Then it doesn't look like we made it.
No, it's... I made it.
It's fine.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Don't take one bean at a time.
You can do all of them.
I will take one bean at a time, thank you.
You can do it, okay?
For some reason, I don't think this is as good as last week.
Two at a time.
Oh no, it's even better.
I'm gonna try two at once, okay?
I'm being ambitious, okay, Ruffians?
Understand, okay?
Chug?
This is natto.
Oh gosh.
What's up?
Okay, I couldn't have it, okay?
I don't need to do it.
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAM
Got two!
That's two right from the start, Ruffians!
Ambitious!
Can you take, like, more?
No, I'm taking another two!
I'm gonna take another two.
Ambitious.
This is gonna take a while, Ruffians.
I wanna see a lot.
Can you do, like, 15 today?
Why is she doing well?
Can I have some water?
No!
Go!
Girl!
I won a Vtuber award!
You're still gonna eat the natto, okay?
I'm gonna have two more!
Here I go, Ruffians!
Moco-chan, why?
Why are you making that face now, huh?
Oh, oh, oh!
Come on, don't make a pain face.
Moco-chan, no, no, no.
That's four.
No, no, that one was tough.
That one was tough.
One more.
No, no, no.
My mouth is all sticky, no.
This creature's suffering.
It's good, Ruffians.
It's extra oily too, Moco-chan.
I feel bad for the natto.
Well, I guess that was a good attempt at a new high record!
High score!
Four beans.
It's just one bean more, but I guess I'll accept it.
Good.
Good job.
I'm proud, but I want you to eat more, okay?
BAU BAU!
Remember, Ruffians, it's the start of a new week, so you can do it!
Challenge yourself to something new, too, just like Moco-chan.
Maybe it doesn't go smoothly, but if it goes, it goes!
BAU BAU!
Now, let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day!
The Doggie of the Day is De-den!
She's so cute!
This is the Ruffian's sister's doggy!
Look at her with the cute toy!
It's a piggy!
A doggy and a piggy!
It looks more like a rhino though.
I don't know.
Apparently she's a bit of a bonehead, but it's okay because you know she has a heart of gold.
As long as the heart is good.
How are those bones in BAU BAU?
Like a... BAU BAU with the squeaky toy.
BAU BAU!
Is that the squeaky toy?
That's the squeaky toy.
What if it's like, BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
No.
I think mine was the best.
I put in a creaky mouth full of salad.
Yeah.
Again.
BAU BAU!
I don't know.
That sounds like a car starting up on a cold day.
BAU BAU!
Oh, you know, Rosy!
Rosy's a cutie with a very cute rosy nose.
Right!
She's a little bit of a troublemaker maybe, but...
That's also what makes her as lovable as she is, you know?
She just wants to enjoy life together with her family.
Even if that maybe means a little bit of mischief.
It's okay.
A little bit of mischief is okay.
BAU BAU!
Today!
Ruffians, where have you been going for walks?
I see.
De-den!
What?!
Oh my gosh!
Christmas fireworks!
Amazing!
And what such a nice photo!
I know what's that.
The tree right there in the front.
Moco-chan, the tree.
So it's supposed to be taken away from the fireworks.
It looks like a Christmas tree.
I guess that's one way to look at it.
Yeah.
They're breathtaking with the tree there.
It's a good outlook.
Thank you!
Thank you for sharing a little bit of your world with us.
I wish we could've been there too.
We were there with you in your heart.
BAU BAU!
And next for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
It's been cold since the beginning of December, and Christmas Day is getting closer and closer.
I'm looking forward to it!
My question is, what flavor or type of cake do you two like to eat on Christmas Day?
Or which kind would you prefer?
Good question.
This is a good question, yeah.
We really like dessert.
Did you know?
Yeah, I know, but we actually don't typically eat cake with Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy on Christmas in the Northwest Passage.
Yeah, it's a bit surprising, right?
But I think for cake,
Ice cream cake.
You know, especially when it's just a solid slab of ice cream.
You know it's ice cream, but you add the word cake onto it because it kind of looks like a cake.
It's in a cake shape.
Yeah.
But for the cake cakes, not ice cream.
Cake cakes.
Actual cake cake.
Cheesecake is yummy too.
Yeah!
But cheese is gross.
But cheesecake is cake.
Cheesecake is yummy, cheese is gross.
That makes sense.
It makes sense, right.
Do you agree?
One more question, like, uh, what is weird with that?
Cheese is gross.
Cheesecake is good.
Yeah.
Yeah, it makes sense.
Agreed.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians, again for everything.
All your doggies, all your questions, your scoops too.
Don't forget to use the hashtag, hashtag FUWAMOCO scoop.
F3S scoop.
And for your other submissions.
But we have homework for you.
Don't forget your homework.
We continue to ask a lot of the Ruffians, huh?
We're good!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for always being a very important part of everything we do.
BAU BAU!
And next we have our upcoming stream, which is tonight!
Tonight we have... De-den!
We're playing the newest Chilla's Art game, but Ruffians, this time I think it's really really really scary.
I think it's seriously scary.
Yeah.
You know, some of them, they weren't that bad.
But this time I'm really worried.
Yeah.
I'm not good at the dark stuff with the flashlight.
But there is a very cute Tanuki!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
This week we have a lot of exciting plans, especially as we get closer to Christmas.
But for the first time ever, we're gonna be releasing two new song covers that are solos!
As you know, back in October we released "Cute na Kanojo" but this time,
FUWAMOCO!
This is Fuwawa.
This is Mococo.
Please check it out!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today.
The very first day of the broadcast.
BAU BAU!
Wow, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Ben!
BAU BAU!
Phillip!
Randy Lee.
BAU BAU!
Jose Cortez.
Nyappoi.
BAU BAU!
Alice.
Kamibakoi.
BAU BAU!
Klaws.
O-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-
Moccha!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!